your doctor will perform a cystoscopy to
diagnose conditions of your urinary
tract your urinary system or urinary
tract produces urine and excretes it
from the body it includes the kidneys
ureters bladder and urethra in men the
prostate gland wraps around the urethra
at the base of the bladder
as blood circulates it passes through
the kidneys where wastes and extra fluid
are removed to create urine the urine
then moves down the ureters to be stored
in the bladder an expandable balloon
shaped muscle during urination urine
leaves the bladder through the urethra
and is expelled from the body
by allowing your doctor to view the
interior of the urethra bladder and the
openings of the ureters a cystoscopy may
reveal the following conditions an
unusual growth such as a polyp sister
tumor a stone in or near the bladder
chronic inflammation or infection a
stricture
or narrowing of the urethra enlargement
of the prostate gland or ulcers in the
bladder wall before your procedure an IV
line may be inserted into your vein to
provide medication your doctor will
begin by applying a local anesthetic to
numb the area once the area is numbed he
or she will gently insert the tip of a
cystoscope into the urethra and slowly
advance it up into the bladder the end
of the cystoscope contains a light
source and lenses which project images
through an eyepiece and onto a video
screen by introducing a clear sterile
solution your doctor will expand the
bladder he or she will carefully examine
the lining of the bladder and urethra by
looking through the eyepiece on the
cystoscope as well as by viewing images
projected onto the video screen
when your doctor is finished the scope
will be removed your doctor can tell you
what was seen immediately after the test
if a biopsy was taken results are
usually available in a few days this
procedure usually lasts about two to ten
minutes
you will usually be able to go home soon
after your cystoscopy your doctor will
likely prescribe antibiotics to prevent
an infection and may offer you
medications to treat any lingering
discomfort